courge patate
aiko chou fleur ce sont quelques-uns des
nombreux et légumes qui ont poussé cet
été au jardin botanique de montréal
il travail n'est pas terminé les
jardiniers récolte les fruits de leur
labeur chaque matin depuis presqu'un
mois
c'est très émouvant parce que on
n'aurait jamais cru qu'on aurait pu
arriver à ce résultat la 357 bacs à
partir d'hier de septembre à la demande
la ville de montréal la vocation des
jardins a été repensé pour la production
alimentaire
c'était peut-être la moitié l'an passé
et cette année c'est très très productif
vous pourrez le voir c'est énormément de
caissettes qu'on donne à des organismes
qui sont dans la gamme maisonneuve dans
rosemont la petite patrie
essentiellement chaque semaine quatre
organismes viennent chercher les légumes
et les fruits fraîchement cueillies pour
la banque alimentaire un élan pour la
vie c'est un cadeau tombé du ciel
l'organisme et des 150 familles avant la
pandémie
il en est de maintenant 300 chaque
semaine des demandes supplémentaires de
bénéficiaires
donc c'est ça on essaye vraiment de
répondre au mieux à leurs besoins et
c'est sûr que d'avoir des produits frais
de qualité ça fait la différence quoi la
ville voit gras elle souhaite mettre de
l'avant d'autres projets d'agriculture
urbaine
on voit avec les pays avec lesquels on
fait à part où ça coûte plus cher à
cause des changements climatiques où il
ya des feux de forêt et cetera donc il
ya des périodes où nos épiceries sont
moins bien garni donc on sait qu'on va
avoir un rôle à jouer qu'on veut y
réfléchir dès maintenant pour le jardin
botanique
la production de cette année est un
succès et un moyen de combattre
l'insécurité alimentaire
ici mark isabel rochât radio canada
montréal